everyone can appreciate great action
enhanced by amazing visuals I know we
can write nice The Bluest system is
another visually jaw-dropping
application that allows digital effects
art digital effects artists to quickly
create explosions fire mist and smoke
plumes plumes I love that word such a
nice word for explosions and the great
thing about explosions other than
pyroclastic effects is that these days
no one gets hurts when they're creating
the computer this software system unique
to ILM significantly reduces turnaround
time it combines fluid solving and final
image rendering on a GPU bypassing the
use of a CPU the Academy presents the
technical achievement award for the
creation of the plume system to
alleviate Maurier I in Sachs and Dan
peponi I know yeah I forgot to hook up
with the teleprompter people as well so
when I think of the interesting projects
that we worked on all had at least one
of the three following ingredients very
good people cool results or and/or big
impacts well I gotta say plume had all
three for me I got to work with great
people both on the technical side with
Ian and Dan but also on the creative
side and I'd like to think through on
Doha and Craig hammock for shaping plume
in the tool that it is today
plume produce images of explosion as you
can see on the on the wheel so I can't
get much cooler than that and then it
ended up having a pretty big impact at
ILM in the effects Department and I'd
like to thank all the effects artists at
ILM for producing these great images and
particularly John Hanson Florin Witzel
and Reinhart pants
Ryan Hopkins finally I'd like to thank
the Academy for this honor and my family
for their support especially my mom Mary
and my brother Danielle thank you
I'd like to thank the Academy and the
SCI tech committee who judging by the
size of the crowd here today must have
worked really hard this year I'd like
I'd like to fight thank Olivier and Ian
especially Olivier for asking me to
collaborate on this fantastic project
I'd like to thank all the artists at ILM
because we just wrote a bunch of
software but software it doesn't run
itself it needs the artists so without
them we're nothing so thanks to them I'd
like to thank my wife Lorraine for being
a fantastic support over the years and
when I was a kid nobody told me that if
I wanted to get an Academy Award I
should study mathematics but that's what
I did and Here I am so so I'm hoping
that maybe some of our shots will
inspire some kids today thank you
I just like to thank my computer
scientist mom and chemist / business's
dad for without whom you know
computational fluid dynamics might have
been a less natural choice I'd like to
thank Industrial Light and Magic for
inspiring me with their images as a
child and for employing me to make those
images some 30 years later I'd like to
thank my computer science 126 ta who I
haven't seen in about 20 years and who
helped me with C pointers and all those
kinds of things Anu ironically is here
tonight getting an award for a
physically based rendering so thanks
Greg Humphries I'd like to I think to
thank the giant killer robots Pete Mike
John and amber for giving me a job in
this industry and without whom my work
would be far less interesting and
probably higher paying
and then and then finally I would like
to thank my wonderful wife Elizabeth and
my two gorgeous daughters Pia and Eloise
for tolerating my sometimes awkward
schedule and for what can only be
described as boundless love and support
thank you